selon une étude 60% des personnes en
couple depuis 10 ans ont trompé au moins
une fois leur femme ou leur alors qui
donc autour de la table plus de 10 ans
voilà c'est quoi qui autour de la table
peut dire oui j'étais en cours en couple
je n'ai jamais trompé qui peut le dire
alors après
c'est bon non faut partir faut pas
tromper faut pas non faut partir
excuse-moi
parce qu'il sait il me connaît depuis
moins de 10 ans donc enfin c'est l'homme
de ma vie donc il est hors de question
enfin bon
quand j'étais jeune je pouvais être avec
quelqu'un et je le trompais bon de toute
façon je vais te dire le seul quoi c'est
toi ici
et toi tu es là tu poses pas les bonnes
questions